dernier leviers de fiscalité pour les
collectivités locales aussi et l'un des
derniers leviers de fiscalité mais
si peu se discuter mais dès l'instant ou
de toute façon le gouvernement et l'État
n'est pas en capacité aujourd'hui de
baisser l'impôt je crois qu'il ne
fallait pas le faire il fallait garder
toutes les ressources par rapport au
sujet que nous avons retraités qui sont
bien plus grave que ceci je voudrais la
il nous reste une minute on va évoquer
ensemble le recours au 49,3 puisque
c'est quand même quelque chose qui sera
marquant dans cette session
parlementaire avec la fin du projet de
loi de finance ce sera au total 10
utilisations du 49-3 depuis le début de
la session qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque
ce chiffre alors les 10 très sincèrement
rien vous savez je suis un vieux
rocardien et et à l'époque de Michel
Robert
on a pratiqué ce genre de choses donc je
me permettrai pas dès l'instant où nous
en avons un au final nous en arrivons à
10 ça c'est la question c'est est-ce
qu'on utilise le 49-3 ou pas et à quel
moment on l'utilise et en réalité ce qui
est très curieux dans cette affaire
c'est qu'on n'utilise pas le 49-3 après
le débat si vous l'aimez dès le début du
débat il a totalement
finalement l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
pu examiner l'ensemble des articles ça
je pense que c'est mauvais du temps de
Michel Rocard voyez le 49-3 venait à la
fin du débat parlementaire c'était tout
à fait différent et je voudrais revenir
encore d'un mot c'est peut-être trop
mais voyez quand on décide de supprimer
la CVAE finalement sans l'accord de
l'assemblée nationale puisque l'article
n'a même pas été examiné à l'Assemblée
on s'est arrêté avant le budget des
collectivités exactement et contre la
vie du Sénat finalement on enlève au
Parlement ce qui sa première règle de
vie votée l'impôt vous voyez c'est sa
première fonction historique et là on le
prive de cette première fonction
historique ça ça c'est historique
[Musique]